I will kill the Mask!
Big brother,
help me!
I'm on the roof of a building.
There's a strange man with a mask on.
The Mask is there?
I won't die without seeing my big brother!
That's the rule of this world. Accept it.
The Mask's aim is to drive people
to suicide from despair.
Is there really a human being
inside the Mask?
May I speak to you?
This realm is an institution
that creates Gods.
What on earth?
What is "Become a God"?
My name is Kazuma Aohara.
Could I say that
I am God Candidate within this realm?
I cannot defy the Mask's orders.
Do you know how to access
the Railgun System?
I want to bring true peace to the world.
If you behave disrespectfully,
you will have to die.
I dare you to do it, you fiend!
I want to die with you!
Mayuko!
You better not direct
your hostility at me.
I'll become God.
I am right about everything!
Anything that they desire.
I will wipe them out, no matter what!
I am going to die.
Die?
I will not die!